[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue sur tv soixante
dix huit pour cette nouvelle édition du
7 8 journal tout de suite les titres de
ce mercredi 31 octobre un voyage en
chine depuis touahri jusqu'au 10 mars le
zoo safari propose cette animation
féerique 600 sculptures lumineuses
géantes avoir à la tombée de la nuit au
sein des jardins du château une
découverte des traditions séculaires
chinoise est aussi du monde animalier
après la ryder cup en septembre le golf
national de saint quentin en yvelines
doit recevoir comme chaque année l'open
de france en 2019
une compétition qui vient de perdre son
statut de rolex et reese et qui est
déplacé de juillet à octobre
qu'est ce que ça change concrètement la
réponse en chronique et puis notre petit
tour au sein des cinémas de 56 saint
quentin en yvelines direction
aujourd'hui l'ugc et skywest nous sommes
allé collecter quelques réactions à la
sortie des salles un film sur l'univers
d'halloween et le biopic sur le groupe
queen et freddie mercury
mais avant de développer ses titres fin
novembre les quoi n'ya rien devront
retourner aux urnes après la démission
de jean-pierre sevestre et de plusieurs
élus
une élection municipale partielle est
programmée à coignières premier tour le
dimanche 25 novembre éventuel deuxième
tour le dimanche de décembre nous
recevons à l'ensemble des listes
candidates sur ce plateau bonsoir didier
fischer en soir vous êtes conseiller
municipal d'opposition du groupe
coignières pour tous et vous conduirez
une liste sans étiquette pour ce scrutin
son nom nouvel élan pour coignières
précisons que vous aviez déjà été tête
de liste aux élections en 2014
c'était tout naturel pour vous de vous
relancer naturel d'hommes
de me relancer à nouveau là en 2018
d'autant plus que j'ai vu quand même à
coignières depuis plus de 11 ans j'ai
été conseiller enfin je suis toujours
conseiller municipal depuis 2008
donc c'est dans la logique des choses
que je présente aujourd'hui une liste
pour défendre en effet les intérêts de
notre commune et vous aviez récoltés en
2014 face à henry pailleux 43,42 % des
suffrages là pour cette élection vous
avez bon espoir de l'emporter mais
écoutez on va pas une élection pour
perdre 1 nous on est motivé on a une
équipe dynamique jeune rajeuni donc
motivé on y va pour gagner bien entendu
on repose le contexte jean pierre
semestre a été contraint à la démission
après quelques mois de tumulte au sein
de la commune il n'avait plus de
majorité qui s'était déchiré au moment
du projet de fusion avec mort pas un
projet qui a été ensuite abandonnés
vous étiez vous d'ailleurs membre de
l'opposition à l'origine d'une
mobilisation citoyenne contre ce projet
qui avait réuni 250 personnes devant la
mairie de coignières on a aussi assisté
à des conseils municipaux ou le la
priorité aujourd'hui
pourquoi dire c'est de tourner la page
revenir au calme oui en fait la priorité
c'est la priorité de notre programme
c'est drôle de revenir à la sérénité la
sérénité le calme on a vécu une période
difficile que les coigné rien n'avait
jamais vécu dans leur histoire
donc je pense qu'aujourd'hui il est
temps de tourner cette page il est temps
de tourner cette page de cette mandature
finalement assez calamiteuse
on voit comment ça se termine donc c'est
l'objectif c'est l'objectif numéro un de
notre projet en tant qu'élu vous l'avez
vécu comment cette période mal mal et
comme beaucoup je pense c'est pas normal
d'arriver à ces situations là c'est pas
normal de s'invectiver dans un conseil
municipal
on n'est pas forcément du même bord
politique on défend pas forcément les
mêmes projets mais au moins au moins
qu'il y ait quand même la courtoisie
nécessaire je dirais pour que les choses
se passent bien
c'était plus le cas je pense que la
décision du préfet sage il remet
finalement la décision au poignet rien
céder quoi ni rien qui vont choisir ce
qu'ils veulent donc et il y a
effectivement plusieurs listes
candidates
il faut vite revenir à des sujets
d'importance ils ont peut-être été mis
de côté avec ses quelques mois de
tumulte il faut revenir très vite
peu importe il faut revenir très vite un
certain nombre de sujets on a dit
réhabilitation à faire vous savez qu'on
a un patrimoine municipal important on a
un gymnase à réhabiliter ça sera ça fait
partie de notre projet mais c'est pas
suffisant il ya aussi des écoles des
écoles qui ceux qui sont quand même
aujourd'hui dans un état qui nécessite
une lourde réhabilitation et ça fait
partie aussi de notre projet alors on
fera pas tout en 14 mois c'est évident
il faudra un petit peu plus de temps
pour notamment les écoles et puis on a
un projet aussi de faire une maison des
associations des familles et des jeunes
donc ça c'est un gros projet qui nous
tient à coeur c'est un projet qu'on
avait depuis 2014
et bien si on est élu et bien on lancera
la concertation pour ce projet ce sera
les premiers dossiers sur votre table
des premiers dossiers à l'heure il y en
ad'autres un bien entendu qui arriveront
sur la table très vite il ya la question
de l'emploi
vous savez on est dans une commune où
nous avons 12 % de la population active
au chômage beaucoup de jeunes en
difficulté dans notre commune liées
justement au manque d'emplois donc ça va
être l'objectif numéro un
accompagné réinsérer et cela il va
falloir faire quelques réformes
importantes notamment la fameuse cellule
emploi nous allons nous y attacher on va
travailler avec les entreprises et on va
aussi travailler avec tous les
organismes sociaux qui existent
effectivement sur le territoire et sur
le territoire de 50 ares notamment un
dernier mot sur votre lit tu es sur ses
colistiers on vous c'est vous on
reconnaît une sensibilité plus à gauche
mais ça va rassembler des sensibilités
différentes se rassemblent des 100 sites
sensibilité différente bien entendu
c'est une liste se dirait de large union
c'est une liste
je dirais dégagé de tout de tout intérêt
politique au sens politicien du terme 1
c'est une liste largement comment dire
motivé je les dis hein ouverte sans
sensibilité politique particulière on
est tous là pour travailler dans
l'intérêt de notre commune on retrouvera
des membres de coignières pour tous le
groupe d'opposition sur bien sûr je
dirais qu'à un bon tiers voire même un
petit peu plus de la liste sont des
membres de poignard pour tout ce qui est
logique mais vient d'horizons différents
d'autres personnes viennent d'autres
personnes d'horizons différents donc et
c'est ce qui va faire la richesse de
cette liste et moi j'étais très très
surpris de voir que l' amalgame s'est
fait très vite et les gens sont contents
de travailler ensemble sont heureux de
travailler ensemble ils ont l'impression
qu'ils vont pouvoir faire quelque chose
de bien pour leur commune donc c'est
fantastique
merci à didier fischer d'avoir été avec
nous merci conseiller municipal
d'opposition à coignières et vous
conduirez la liste sans étiquette nouvel
élan pour coignières rappelons que le
premier tour de cette élection
municipale partielle est au programme le
25 novembre un deuxième tour et est
également programmée le 2 décembre et
les jardins du château de thoiry se met
en lumière pendant cinq mois le au
safari invite les visiteurs à un voyage
à travers la chine et ses traditions à
la tombée de la nuit est des sculptures
géantes illumine les lieux découverte
avec ce reportage de manon varaldo
girafe crapaud pan ou encore lyon
entièrement réalisé à la main et
recouvertes de tissu ses oeuvres uniques
s'allume à la tombée de la nuit
touahri accueille le plus grand festival
de lanternes chinoises en france
six artistes chinois de la ville de
gombe
kaiku une tradition depuis des centaines
d'années de faire des lanternes et
maintenant avec la technologie lauder de
faire des lanternes géantes
on a donc derrière moi une
reconstitution du temple du ciel à
beijing qui fait dix sept mètres de haut
en face le château est mis en valeur
avec un spectacle de sons et lumières
avec toujours des éléments de la culture
chinoise présent fleurs dragon base ou
encore lanternes chinoises jouent
vraiment su associer donc donc la chine
et les animaux dont qui sont propres à
thoiry ni imposer et les animaux auront
une expression les curieux peuvent
assister à un spectacle de la troupe de
théâtre de sichuan
on y retrouve des équilibristes
acrobates et transformiste du visage
comme dans le théâtre traditionnel
chinois ils se produisent en face de
l'une des créatures phare de l'événement
un dragon de 65 mètres de long le
visiteur peut ensuite continuer l
aventure en traversant la forêt remplie
d'animaux lumineux en spectacle de plus
de 600 lantern répartis en 30 tableaux
de jour comme de nuit c'est magnifique
quand on voit le travail les détails que
dessus on est en paix on est bien c'est
trop bien
tout au long du parcours d'un kilomètre
5 dans les jardins du château des
dizaines d'autres animaux tels et
volatiles zèbre ou encore iguane ces
animaux captent le regard des visiteurs
parfois venus de loin
c'est vraiment magique et magnifique
c'est une super belle expérience toute
une facette de la culture chinoise à
découvrir à thoiry pendant cinq mois
jusqu'au 10 mars un mot de ce sport à
présent l'open de france se joue chaque
année au golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines le tour
européen vient de dévoiler à son
calendrier pour la saison 2010 8 2019 et
le tournoi ce tournoi de l'open de
france se jouera l année prochaine en
octobre et non plus en juillet pour
décrypter cette actualité et notre
journaliste sportif michael et me
d'euros bonsoir bonsoir gorilles et
c'est toujours un plaisir
l'espèce mais également pour moi alors
ni quel était ce qu'il faut se réjouir
de cette annonce au contraire s'alarme
est alors un peu des deux grégory il ya
du positif et du négatif dans cette
annonce de l'european tour l'organisme
qui gère les tournois de golf sur le
circuit européen
on va commencer par le positif si vous
le voulez bien grégory l'open de france
sera déplacée du 17 au 20 octobre 2019
auparavant le tournoi à saint quentinois
était situé entre l' us et le british
open fin juin deux des plus gros rendez
vous de l'année une date pas forcément
propice pour attirer des superstars et
on l'a vu sur ces dernières années les
américains et les agro joueurs européens
comme rory mcilroy faisait donc souvent
l'impasse sur la compétition les
spectateurs du golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines pouvait avant
tout observé sur le green des joueurs
français ou des joueurs européens venus
chercher quelques points au classement
cette fois ci à l'open de france sera
l'avant dernier rendez vous de la saison
régulière et n'aura pas de gros thon à
face à lui hormis la tournée asiatique
sur le pitch et tous les joueurs
pourrait donc opter chez plus facilement
pour le plus vieux rendez vous européen
du positif on l'a compris côté points
négatifs une telle lâché par son sponsor
chinois à chênée qui n'a pas souhaité à
soutenir l'événement pour une troisième
année consécutive l'open de france
quitte officiellement le cercle des
rolex series les meilleurs tournois
européens
il sera remplacé numériquement par abou
dhabi le rendez vous n'aura pas de
nouveau sponsor titre et se contentera
d'un rôle de second couteau entre 2 et 4
millions d'euros et de dotation maximum
pour l'année prochaine contre plus de 7
millions d'euros sur le deux dernières
années ce qui ne devrait pas forcément
inciter les grosses têtes d'affiché à
venir jouer à pour pour cette dotation a
second point négatif la météo un je ne
vous apprends rien à grégory le tournoi
ne se disputera plus
soleil à radio sur le pwa dernier
week-end du mois de juin mais sûrement
sous une légère pluie automnale du 17 au
20 octobre
sauf si la météo est aussi clémente que
cette année ce qu'il n'y ait ce qui
n'est pas forcément l'idéal pour les
spectateurs ce qui peut aussi découragé
de nombreux golfeurs américains habitués
aux chaleurs floridienne ou
californienne tiger woods s'était par
exemple plein des températures fraîches
pendant la dernière ryder cup en france
au mois de septembre alors que le
thermomètre affiche et un peu plus de 20
degrés alors imaginez avec un temps
comme celui que l'on connaît cette
semaine grégory est très frileux ce
tiger woods merci l'honneur six ans
qu'elle s'est d'ailleurs vous michael
qui est allé faire notre petit tour
hebdomadaire au sein à des cinémas saint
quentinois avec benjamin foucault et
micros tendus à la sortie des salles de
l'ugc skywest à propos de deux films
l'un sur le thème d'halloween c'est bien
normal et l'autre c'est un biopic sur la
vie de freddie mercury et son groupe
mythique de queen regardez c'est un très
bon film je pense pour les enfants c'est
drôle et ça fait un petit peu peur en
même temps c'est bien et qu'il ya plein
on pourra lui ça fait peur mais c'est
bien c'est sympa ouais c'est c'est un
bon film pour pour la journée de
l'halloween on se prépare pour ce soir
tout doucement c'est bien réaliste avait
peur
j'avais déjà vu le 1 je suis pas déçu du
2 et je trouve que les huiles les effets
spéciaux sont bien faits bouygues se dit
c'est vraiment très très bien les
musiques sont bons son génial c'est
queen
quand on est fan c'est un super film et
même si on n'est pas femme les fans
l'histoire de deux freddie mercury elle
est très très très poignante très très
prenante je suis fan de rock depuis
depuis tout petit et que pour moi ça me
touche encore plus je pense que
enfin il ya ça qui jours et puis il ya
aussi le fait que c'est très bien
interprétée par les acteurs ne connaît
pas vraiment l'histoire de frida mercury
ça permet de voir un petit peu autrement
une autre façon et puis de découvrir des
choses sur lui de voir sa vie finalement
enfin vous vous préparez peut-être
actuellement pour votre soirée halloween
à voisins le bretonneux on l'a fêté à
des à loïc end dernier l'association
soudja organisait sa première soirée
tour de la terreur c'était samedi à la
salle de la tour
trois projections de films proposés les
propos sont recueillis par manon varaldo
l'objectif c'est de créer une soirée au
sur le thème déjà d'halloween mais aussi
créer une soirée un moment où il n'y a
pas nécessairement beaucoup de soirées
dans le coin parce que ben il fait pas
beau alors il fait froid donc les gens
ne sortent pas nécessairement où on
puisse envie de se retrouver à
l'intérieur à l'intérieur d'un lieu donc
c'est pour ça qu'on a créé sa soirée
pour créer un événement bas cette époque
de l'année où il n'y a pas beaucoup
d'événements c'est la fin de ce journal
belle soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]